hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slow-mo guys doing this job for several
years now often leaves Lou with quite
random questions in my head such as can
C4 deflect a bullet out of the air solid
question couldn't exactly do that in the
studio so we come again to the Colorado
School of Mines our favorite place to go
to when we need massive explosion
yeah this is a really interesting
experiment because I kind of know quite
a bit about explosives and bullets
having a background in it you don't
really know much about it absolutely
nothing but everyone else around us here
knows so much more than I do and nobody
knows what's going to happen this feels
like a proper mythbuster Style video
like it doesn't matter what happens
we'll have very interesting footage to
look at it's always exciting when all
the experts are excited to do it yes
it's a real experiment and they're going
to find out some interesting information
where do you get experts being like you
know what I don't really know exactly
yeah why don't we find out all right Dan
this is a hell of a setup compared to
our usual stuff why don't you run us
through it it's a whole thing you've got
a nine millimeter pistol here an arrest
which is going to be remotely fired with
electronics for consistency so we always
get the same point today got high
quality nine mil ammunition just to ball
round but it's sort of mil-spec so it's
got the consistency of about 1250 feet
per second which is going to be very
important it's going to come out of here
here this piece of cardboard with tape
and wire on this is a high-tech piece of
kit it's basically a wire break so when
the bullet travels through here it
breaks a circuit and that gives us
accurate timing for when the explosives
need to be initiated it can also set up
our cameras as well so bullet comes
through here at 1250 feet per second and
then we can have our explosives shorter
or longer time between when it initiates
So currently the explosives about foot
away from the bullet yeah it's about a
foot above the bullet and about two feet
away from the yeah the the brake now the
reason we've got the wire brakes so
close to the actual explosives rather
than closer to the gun itself is because
it cuts down on inconsistency of the
bullet so there's a lot less travel time
here and here than there would be
between the gun and here then coming out
of here maybe we'll see some tumbling or
I don't really know what's going to
happen but we're going to have this
target here so that we can see where are
our rounds are landing so if we end up
with a hole below our test shot we know
something's happened we know something's
up I think my favorite part was when you
referred to a piece of wire on tape as a
high-tech piece of kit
this is the free fly Ember this is just
looking at the entire thing to see the
whole experiment about 800 frames a
second a little bit closer on our usual
4K this is running a thousand frames a
second that'll see pretty much if the
bullet goes up or down afterwards if
it's not obscured by the explosion TMX
7510 maybe 200 000 frames a second
you'll be triggering that one I'll be
triggering that one and then the School
of Mines have provided their usual kit
the shimatsu we used last time black and
white camera can film for about 250 odd
frames it's a very short duration but
we'll get about 10 seconds of extremely
fast millions of frames a second footage
because we have such a short amount of
time to record with the shimatsu we're
using the trigger from The Wire break to
also trigger the cameras and the
explosives yeah the entire duration of
the shimatsu is could be measured in
nanoseconds really so completely
impossible to trigger by hand and that's
it we're going to be taking lots of
pictures of this yes
okay so that was our control shot yeah
we've got a successful hit through here
so when we put our wire break it will be
able to trigger the cameras and the
explosives it's a bit of windage ah
we'll uh yeah throw our results just
spotted that yeah right out of the
window well let's see if we can do
something about that but hopefully we'll
have a you know if if there's a
deviation hopefully it'll be pretty
obvious yes I'm hoping to get below the
10 at least yeah and then maybe more but
we'll see all right I think it's time we
wire up some uh
some C4 with C4 70 grams of C4 loaded in
will now hopefully learn a lot about the
exposure and the timing
that's the plan are you ready yep okay
though
okay so that was a bit of a failure we
only heard the gun go off no C4
explosion yeah it turns out the brake
screen here the bullet went through
between two wires and pushed them to the
side yeah let's flip it over look at the
way it's it's
yeah it's still it's like in one piece
it's like gone perfect through through
between two of them and like moved them
to the side it just pushed them like
curtains yeah yeah if it had just
detached a little bit it would have gone
off so now I have a break screen with
much tighter Loops everyone's ready burn
the hole fire in the hole fire in the
hole
well that went off that's a chest you
put it in the chest oh so our first
indicator is going to be the target
itself hmm
control shot first of all and then where
the wire didn't get cut yeah now it
seems to have gone above it yeah I think
we need to look at the footage see what
we can see and uh then we can test and
adjust explosives or timing or yeah
whatever needs to be changed
bullets coming in
just brushes past that
oh it's late okay yeah
it's really late that is late oh it's
really I think some timing adjustments
might need to be met oh you know this is
the first shot I'll still learn from the
exposure on this though
it's like several shock waves too oh
yeah look look at this look there's a
Shockwave yeah there's one and then
there's a second there's like a
secondary one which maybe bounced off
the back wall oh through the flame yeah
something like that and then the one
coming off the floor there I think
you're right it's coming off the back
wall because they're not far from it all
right so we need to work on timing I
think so and uh I will work on exposure
all right we're ready though
this is the last one I think and this is
this one so it's pretty consistent so I
don't I think we've had an effect on
target which means that we might have
been too early yeah or it just doesn't
work
so um yeah I mean let's I'm still
enjoying the footage yeah me too maybe
the maybe we'll have a little look at
the cameras in there that will tell us
more
Okay so we've discovered that at 187
500 frames a second the bullet was a
thousand frames too late because there's
no delay between the paper and the
explosion yeah the only thing we can do
is just move the paper closer to the gun
right while keeping all the other
distances the same okay an explosion is
bright it's so difficult to expose the
boat do you know what I like
got all these like special delay things
and trading all this Detonator here yeah
move the piece of cardboard back
probably about a meter
bung it there yeah yeah just move it
there yeah yeah yeah
fire in the hole fire the hole
maybe jump that time you were the one
saying fire in the hole I know I don't
know why I didn't expect it I was like
what's going on did the target's down
what does that mean
okay
all right back at four res because the
bullet is moving slow enough that we'll
see it and I'm very much relying on the
explosion to light the bullet there it
is oh yeah you can still see it
again oh it's in there and it's been hit
by the Shockwave doesn't seem to have
done anything really it was a bit behind
it though it won't see that the bullet
just being like what was that is a close
one didn't even tumble it that's I'm
surprised I'm so surprised even though
the explosions behind it the Shockwave
has already hit it yeah that second shot
quiver has hit it too yeah and it didn't
even budge that really gives a
perspective on how quickly the explosion
is moving compared
but already okay
um getting there on timing I'll do a
little bit more maths with the team and
we'll nudge it back a little bit more
all right you want the number from when
it's directly under the explosive yeah
eighteen eight four eight and detonation
is a 18732
yeah look at that
[Music]
oh wow yeah you could probably go even
lower than on the exposure and now for a
quick and cheeky ad read this video is
very kindly sponsored by Shady Rays
Shady Rays is an independent sunglasses
company that offer premium polarized
sunglasses with durable frames high
quality Optics just as good as any
expensive brand here you can see a
couple of the pairs I've chosen I've got
quite the schnoz and often struggle to
find sunglasses that look alright on my
head but I'm a fan of how these look
I've enjoyed wearing them out and about
towards the end of this summer and if
you're into winter sports they have
quick swap snow lenses to move
effortlessly between full sun and low
light environments Shady Rays has a
pretty insane protection policy every
pair you buy from day one is backed by
lost and broken Replacements even if you
sit on them or lose them day one they'll
send you a replacement pair no questions
asked if you don't love your shady Rays
you can exchange them for a new pair or
return them for free within 30 days if
you'd like to support this Channel and
help us fund much bigger video ideas
like this one one please go to
shadyraise.com use the code slo-mo and
get 50 off two or more pairs of
polarized sunglasses big thanks to Shady
race for sponsoring even bigger thanks
to you for listening now back to the
booms okay the sun is moving behind us
now so the star of this footage is going
to be incredibly dark but hopefully the
explosion will light the bullet I think
we're getting closer with it yeah we're
diving it in we're nearly there you
ready ready fingers crossed
the hole
that's the sound you like it's low it's
not that much lower not that much though
it's not as low as I was hoping but it
is low now I may have just knew yeah
whoa oh gosh that was so quick and
sudden I don't think I saw the bullet
I'm gonna have to go Friend by frame was
it even there oh it is there oh yeah
it's just next to it under it it's right
there surely this is going to be
definitive right and it's still blown
out it looks like when you look into the
sun it moves like an inch but based on
our Target
completely uneffective yeah I am shocked
unlike the bullet yep yeah timing's good
yeah we need more power yeah more power
so we're going twice the amount of
explosives which is more than twice the
power which is why we're all crammed in
here throw the hole fire in the hole
fire in the hole
this is the first shimatsu shot that
captured the bullet as well as the
explosion it looks like someone's just
hung a bullet there and look here frame
by frame you can actually see the
explosion oh yeah you can see the
propagation through the actual explosive
itself look at that too it's a
completely different shape it's much
less spherical than the 100 grams that's
amazing
it's over here I'm aiming so we can see
the target the bullet if it is being
affected isn't being affected on camera
so let's see what happens here
Nicole what's all this shock over stuff
here
that's box from the C4 there it is oh oh
yeah it's like a fast moving spark you
have to pick it out from amongst the
Sparks but it's definitely there
again it does it does seem to have been
affected at all just rushing out of the
explosion Blown Away not unlike the book
is there so much later than those Sparks
and then it catches up to them I guess
it must just have so much like energy
still behind it
going to go in the Target on camera
oh oh it just went in right was it blue
Target move moving
explosion yeah before the before the
bullet even gets there that's why our
shots are all over this time it's
because the Shockwave is blowing the
target out of the way yeah unless we
make the target immovable solid like
metal paper yeah what fools I think it's
under the zero you think it's this yeah
because our previous effort was here I
think if anything the C4 made the bullet
really accurate it's made it more
accurate
yeah
okay so we hit it with 200 the bullet is
pretty much right below slightly ahead
of the explosive
uh we're gonna go back to 100 now but
yeah this time we've moved the plate
slightly further back again so hopefully
we'll get a bit more time under pressure
from the explosion and the boat will be
a bit further
this side so it might start before the
bullets even yeah that might give us our
best chance yeah I think so if this
doesn't do it nothing nothing will that
we're gonna do yeah okay you ready yep
all right though follow the hole
all right so it sounds like we have a uh
wait yeah lightning storm coming in so
that
there's potentially our final attempt
yeah lightning and explosives don't mix
very well if the timing was the same and
it didn't deviate I just don't think
it's gonna do it yeah I think we've got
our answer if it didn't deviate to
capture all the bright detail at the
beginning of the C4 explosion I've
stopped the lens all the way down on
this shot now good luck finding the
bullet and this is a hundred thousand
frames a second
oh wow
Panama and the bullet oh yeah it's right
beneath it um
you couldn't be more on that is it's
just it's just that isn't insane like
even though the bullet is so small
because we want to see the explosion
that is a bullet sat directly under the
first microsecond of an explosion from
C4 that is pretty cool as a moment in
time that hat is absolutely insane yeah
that happened and we captured it there
but essentially blown up a bullet there
I thought that it would be at that point
if we nailed it with C4 in the ground
yeah you know got a million frames a
second the temporal difference between
those two is insane the bullet's barely
moving to be honest that is definitive
let's back down here again so it's lower
but it's not any lower than just the
random pattern we've been getting
throughout the day with the wind it's
not a considerable amount lower that I
would be like yeah yeah explosions you
know reflect bullets peel up the thing
just so we can see the sand and see the
true impacts yeah so you can see yeah
all of them just in there it's a pretty
tight grouping that's a tight grouping
yeah I'd be happy with that if I was
shooting for 25 yards myth myth that no
one was asking about bastard hey
everyone everyone
yeah cheers guys
yeah I think that's our answer you know
what even though it didn't happen I
still love the footage or at least not
with this position of the bullet with
this amount of C4 yeah we could change
like the gun we use yeah and the amount
of explosives that sort of thing yeah
unfortunately we've run out of light
really and uh
we have to move on but there is
lightning as well there's also lightning
coming which
I hope it doesn't uh
strike one of the objects from one of
our upcoming videos because that would
make but make it more powerful that
would make it more powerful but for me
that was such an interesting experiment
just because there was so much at play
and so many different options and things
that could have happened like if you for
instance get just a bullet next to an
explosion blowed up well it's gonna go
flying obviously but because it has so
much energy behind it and it's
aerodynamic you know it's cutting
through the air with the rifling and
everything just breathe seem to Breeze
through yeah I honestly wish we could
have done like five straight days of
this just changing every variable like
the timings and the even the speed of
the bullet the footage was class though
just the fact that you could see a
bullet basically paused under a very
fast moving explosion it puts both of
those things into perspective of each
other which in real time look completely
identical
I'd say more of an inconclusive
okay a revisit then that's what you're
saying yeah I just want to come back and
try again give us five years a bit muddy
and uh yeah we'll be back again yeah all
right big old fat thanks to the Colorado
School of Mines there's information
about them in the description of this
video if you want to find out more about
what they do hopefully you enjoyed this
video and we've got plenty of other
videos filmed right here at the Colorado
School of Mines have a little peek
little cheeky peek cheeky peek